[Musique]
messieurs bonjour bonjour vous interview
aujourd'hui pour un site internet qui
s'appelle singer view on voudrait avoir
votre avis sur la crise finances au
développement des finances peut-être
avoir votre avis percy dans votre
capacité d'expertisé peut-être deux
terrains pour jean manuel j'aurais dû
alors aux ans présentez vous bonjour
j'ai travaillé pendant 30 ans dans le
monde de la finance comme trader et
après comme conseiller de différentes
formes de l'investissement est depuis
trois ans j'ai arrêté les finances pour
nous consacrer un moteur de recherche il
s'appelle cointe j'ai aussi créé un
guide finances appelle le fric j'avais
dit jean 1989 et où j'ai expliqué
pourquoi j'allais arrêter de faire du
trading alors moi bonjour re bonjour
tout à fait est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement bon moi j'ai
j'ai fait de la finance pendant 35 ans
est donc en banque et en banque
d'affaires et en ce moment je travaille
dans trois entreprises une qui a été
créé il ya 15 ans et qui fait du de
l'intermédiation
et qui s'appelle tradition une autre qui
est à lausanne et à londres une autre
qui finance
l'infrastructure et qui est devenu un
leader mondial et enfin une affaire
immobilière que j'ai
aidé à créé il ya 20 ans avec un prêt de
200 mille dollars et qui aujourd'hui
pèse 200 millions en ayant fait quelques
investissements judicieux vous avez
oublié une carte dans votre manche vous
êtes aussi
important de la commission trilatérale
oui la commission trilatérale regroupe
des tas de gens et donc je suis l'un
d'entre eux d'accord je vais vous poser
la première question pour entrer dans le
vif du sujet on a vu récemment le
plafond de la dette américaine arrivé à
son terme ou voit le plafond de la dette
américaine arrivée tous les six mois son
terme
mais la croissance américaine semble
repartir est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer un petit peu cette
différence de perception entre un état
qui arrive à tous les six mois a demandé
qu'on relève le plafond de sa dette et
une croissance qui a l'air ou qui semble
repartir à hervé
elle repart pour une raison qui ne
dépend ni des américains ni de nous
c'est un cycle et les cycles économiques
dure entre 4 et 8 9 ans et nous entrons
très probablement dans un cycle plus
favorable après qu'il y ait eu
destruction de richesse de façon à ce
que les méthodes anciennes et les
industries un peu trop sur année aux
états unis et ailleurs se renouvelle et
là en ce moment et on entre dans un
cycle différent alors la dette
américaine
elles augmentent et elles augmentent
d'une façon qui ne me paraît pas
démesuré
étant donné les 320 millions d'habitants
et les 24 trillions de dollars
qui caractérise
voilà jean manuel ros ans qu'est ce que
vous pouvez me dire un petit peu sur
votre métier passé de traders qu'est ce
que vous avez pu voir dans les salles de
marché comment comment quel était votre
rôle
d'abord un mot sur la dette américaine
quand j'étais aux états unis où sera la
première fois que le marché était
inquiet pour la dette américaine de mon
expérience je crois que c'était en 1980
étaient des mairies kane a toujours été
renouvelé et comme le dit monsieur qu'à
moi elle grandit mais dans dix mois vite
que l'économie américaine et surtout en
ce moment et si l'économie américaine
grandissent si vite en ce moment c'est
parce que il ya bien sûr un cycle
nouveau mais ce site est caractérisée
par deux choses à mon avis qu'ils sont
majeurs et qui explique pourquoi la
croissance de la richesse de demain va
régler les problèmes d'hier ce que
beaucoup d'analystes refuse de voir et
donc les gens continuent
je dirais comme des bovins à être
négatif sur le marché qui monte depuis
cinq ans et bien c'est parce que la
richesse de demain va régler les
problèmes d'aujourd'hui d'hier pourquoi
parce qu'il ya un milliard d'êtres
humains qui vont accéder à la classe
moyenne ils vont le faire avec la
maîtrise de technologies d'information
de savoir qui sont sans précédent dans
l'histoire de l'humanité donc ça c'est
la force qui vient et ça fait cinq ans
que des marchés montent et ça fait cinq
ans que les mêmes de l'analyse vous
dites c'est épouvantable ça va très mal
ça va se casser la gueule en nous lisant
le journal d'hier nous rallier on s'en
fout ce qui compte c'est le journal de
demain
ça c'est ce que je vais vous dire sur ce
sujet je vais je vais vous poser une
question sur la d sa démarche est la
profession de trader est-ce que les
traders s'occupent un petit peu des
fondamentaux de l'économie où ils font
simplement de l'analyse technique est ce
que c'est comment on fait pour être
trader comment niveau paris par exemple
sur les pétroliers est ce que vous avez
quelqu'un qui dans les landes et sa
démarche est fait de la veille sur les
produits pétroliers ou sur les nouvelles
technologies est ce que tous les matins
vous avez une fiche d'analystes si vous
renseigne sur l'arrêté les fondamentaux
de l'économie le ce qu'il faut faire une
réponse un petit peu longue parce que
c'est une question complexe d'abord il
ya beaucoup de gens qui se disent
traders et qu'ils sont que des courtiers
les fautives ne sont pas avec la
différence entre un trader est quelqu'un
qui prend une décision qui engage des
capitaux sur les marchés qui ont salé
marchés des capitaux est un courtier
quelqu'un qui appelle un trader pour lui
suggérer une transaction évidemment ce
sont des niveaux de commandes hier il
faut pour l'un et l'autre des métiers
des talents différents pour être
courtier il faut être un bon vendeur est
au fond si on donne des mauvaises idées
c'est embêtant à court terme mais enfin
on a toujours trouvé un autre trader
quand on en a ruiné à la banque on
engage dans un autre et donc des
courtiers ou
vraiment doivent être des bons vendeurs
plutôt des 12 analystes il ya des
analystes dans la société de courtage et
parmi les traders le monde moderne et
crée beaucoup beaucoup de spécialités
c'est pour ça que c'est difficile de
vous répondre d'un coup je le symbole
dans ces spécialités il ya des gens qui
font du trading macroéconomiques c'est
sur des analyses et où il faut un coup
d'oeil globale sur ce qui se passe dans
le monde qui vous refais qui vous feront
telle information quand j'étais trader
évidemment je ne lisais jamais le
journal et je n'écoutais jamais personne
ce qui m'intéressait à moi c'était les
prix la vitesse à cadix fort mais la
façon dont je les voyais bouger et comme
je faisais surtout beaucoup d'options
les différences de prix entre une option
et l'autre qui me permettait de prendre
des décisions donc c'était un mix à mon
époque c'est extrêmement longtemps de
l'analyse macroéconomique extrêmement
rapide et de décisions d'investissement
basées sur les prix relatifs de
différents instruments qui était de
temps en temps trop cher ou pas cher ça
beaucoup évolué il ya beaucoup de choses
maintenant et
ce qui est important aujourd'hui
c'est que les méthodes ont évolué et la
complexité des modèles mathématiques
s'est accru et demande des gens de plus
en plus performants et la vraie question
c'est
qui doit prendre des positions et pour
moi les établissements bancaires ne
devrait pas prendre des positions pour
compte propre
quel qu'il soit parce que il joue de
plus en plus des sommes importantes qui
peuvent mettre en cause les dépôts dont
ils ont la responsabilité
parler des effets
des effets de levier et puis à quoi quel
est le rôle d'une banque le rôle d'une
banque et de prendre de l'argent qui
vient des clients et de le mettre à la
disposition d'autres clients qui veulent
créer de la croissance économique riff
de la richesse voilà bon alors je ne
pense pas que
d'une façon très pointue lorsqu'une
banque
joue le marché gagnent quelquefois des
centaines de millions en jouant le
marché elle contribue au développement
économique
j'aurais dû elle est ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer un petit peu la philosophie
les salles de marché philosophie des des
personnes qui évoluent dans les salles
de marché est ce que le but premier
salles de marché c'est de prendre de
l'argent de faire de l'argent et de re
prêter de l'argent c'est de prendre de
l'argent et de prendre de l'argent
et
il ya beaucoup de choses et dans une
salle de marché dans des salles de
marchés il ya certainement beaucoup
d'équipés qui ont beaucoup de rôles
différents je voudrais juste prendre un
petit peu
devrait prendre un peu de recul je vais
prendre un peu de recul je vous réfère
non génériques
historiquement et à mon expérience a été
que le rôle principal de l'ensemble des
acteurs à essaye a été de créer de la
complexité qui leur permettait de
prendre de l'argent directement dans la
poche de leurs clients en leur vendant
des choses qu'ils ne comprenaient pas à
des prix qui était trop haut est-ce que
ça c'est l'essence de d'activité
complexité des des trente dernières
années après il n'ya pas que ça je veux
pas qu'on pense qu'il n'ya que ça mais
il ya beaucoup de ça et c'est pour ça
que les banques se sont transformés en
gigantesques machines à vendre des
produits d'un côté il ya un trader
quelque part qui fait un produit très
complexe et qui le fait le plus cher
possible et après il ya une équipe même
si selon l'équipe ya marqué
magic directeur et associé gérant pour
le moyen-orient le gars qui fait ça
c'est quand même un gars qui au fond ne
comprend rien au pressing du produit et
la façon dont il est structuré la façon
dont on le met à disposition du client
et ce qu'il rapporte lorsqu'il est vendu
à la banque mais ce qu'il sait c'est que
il a tout un tas de clients qu'elles il
faut qu'ils en vendent un maximum donc
ça c'est ce qui s'est passé ça n'était
pas évidemment le but originel le but
originel serait de faire en sorte que
des entreprises qui ont besoin d'argent
et les acteurs positifs de l'économie
qui savent prendre des capitaux créé
d'emplois et créer de la richesse puisse
avoir tout le temps cette somme à leur
disposition hélas dans les banques
françaises aujourd'hui nous en sommes
très loin
hervé je vais vous poser une question
pour rebondir un petit peu sur
l'actualité on a vu il ya pas très
longtemps au scandale du libor lurie
bord la manipulation de certains taux
interbancaire par des traders et des
grandes banques
je voudrais avoir votre opinion vos
hommes d'expérience est ce que c'est une
logique est ce que c'est une pratique
courante
est ce que les états de temps en temps
sont au courant est ce que qu'est ce que
vous en pensez qu'un trader fixe un prix
passe en intranet des informations à ses
copains traders pour fixer un peu les
prix d'une façon un peu
obscur
c'est une pratique courante
c'est une pratique courant parce que les
directions bancaires n'ont pas mis en
oeuvre
la formule david rockefeller pour lâcher
ce qui a permis à la chase pendant les
quarante ans où j'étais avec eux de ne
pas avoir de difficultés liées à des
pratiques douteuses quelle était cette
règle s'il y a un doute il n'ya pas de
doute c'est à dire que chaque fois qu'un
trader chaque fois qu'un directeur
chaque rencontre et est pratiquée dès
des
décisions contraires à l'éthique de base
d'une maison ils étaient renvoyés
cela signifie que
toutes ces pratiques il faut prendre
comme hypothèse qu elles sont connues
des chefs de services qu'elles sont
connues des directions générales et
qu'elles sont tolérés à cause des
bénéfices importants que ces pratiques
induisent et pour la banque et pour les
membres de l'équipe
une fois de plus ou moins quelque chose
de précis là-dessus le
mécanisme précis de perversion du
système dans les cas où il a été
perverti car il n'a pas été pas de
référence à l'autre car il n'a pas aidé
pervertit tout le temps et partout mais
le mécanisme précis c'est suivant et
geôles date parce que je les ai vus dans
la fin des années 80 à un moment donné
dans les finances la finance a porté
principalement à ses propriétaires chez
goldman sachs les sabreuses et non ceux
des propriétaires s'étaient les
associés-gérants et ils étaient
responsables sur leurs biens et donc
quand il y avait un doute y avait pas de
doute parce que le risque était pour eux
un moment donné ces maisons sont
devenues des sociétés par actions
l'actionnaire en bourse était celui qui
portait le risque et les chefs de
service des directeurs c'est à dire les
chefs se sont aperçus d'une chose
merveilleuse ci donnait beaucoup
beaucoup de bonus a beaucoup d'indiens
ils pouvaient a réclamé 1 pour eux et le
chef du chef aussi et le chef du chef
aussi et finalement ça est devenu
exclusivement uniquement oui une course
aux bonus et c'est ça qui a ouvert la
porte à des excès alors il n'y a pas eu
que des excès mais des eu beaucoup
d'excès le deuxième raison c'est que les
contrôles internes ont considérablement
failli quand je prends une banque où
vous avez quand même une responsabilité
direction générale il nous a fallu
quatre ans alors que j'étais conscient
un peu du marché puisque j'étais trader
au début de ma vie professionnelle
pour installer des contrôles en
profondeur sur toutes ces transactions
et les auditeurs ont mis des années à
attirer dans leurs rangs d'anciens
traders pour pouvoir vérifier à des
questionnaires pour des questions de
salaires pour des questions de confort
comment est ce qu'on fait entrer deux
traders dans une équipe de dix
contrôleur s'est pas aisée à gérer et
c'est donc tout le monde a été en retard
et tout le monde a été en retard à la
fois parce que les sommes en jeu pour
les entreprises était très important les
gains pour les individus encore plus et
donc il y à une connivence généralisée
on va revenir à l'actualité on va
rebondir là sur actualité avec les
amendes que certaines grandes banques
ont reçu les gouvernements et des
autorités de régulation des marchés
pour faire une comparaison une grande
banque qui a payé son amende pour faire
le parallèle c'est l'équivalent village
de 25 euros pour quelqu'un qui gagne 50
mille euros c'est à dire une broutille
d'hervé je vais rebondir sur vous est ce
que les états ils comprennent quelque
chose parce que là la complexité des
mécanismes de marché de nissan aux
chinoises et légalisme de salles de
marché la complicité des traders nombre
une pas les régulateurs des
gouvernements
le mot les états est un mot vague il ya
des il y à des directions spécialisées
au trésor d'accord on va prendre
l'exemple de bercy elles ont les
fonctionnaires de bercy sont
suffisamment compétent et courageux
genre demander des comptes ils le font
ils ont amélioré leur équipe ils
n'arrivent pas pas plus que les
auditeurs extérieur à vérifier le fin
fond et le détail des opérations qui
sont faites et qu'il arrive que
une banque que je connais très bien a
perdu 200 millions de dollars qui sont
qui ont été comptabilisés un mois après
l'arrivée des auditeurs des commissaires
aux comptes et des des contrôleurs en
d'autres termes ces opérations sont
extraordinairement complexes
et
l'état les commissaires aux comptes les
organismes de contrôle interne sont
rarement doté été rarement de thé des
sommes qu'il fallait il le sent beaucoup
plus aujourd'hui jeu manu alors
je pense que il y a toujours et il y
aura encore des problèmes spécifiques ou
le contrôle est difficile le contrôle
est un peu lent les gens qui font de
contrôle n'ont pas tous le pouvoir tout
l'axé et au fond finalement ils peuvent
avoir toujours un petit peu de retard
cependant je pense qu'une façon
systémique si on prenait toute fille
dans le système financier comprend deux
dates 2007 quand le système financier
était truffé de ce prime de truc
extrêmement dangereux qui allait
exploser et 2013 ou 2014 aujourd'hui je
pense que d'une façon globale ça va
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup mieux et moi
je suis encore aujourd'hui très positif
sur l'économie mondiale sur la
croissance et sur des marchés je pense
bien sûr qu'une crise est possible je ne
crois pas qu'elle viendra de ce même
genre de problème
il faudrait le journal d'après demain et
je ne vais pas je ne sais plus je ne
peux pas dire chine
en général il vient toujours un endroit
surprenant donc
c'est difficile à dire là je veux pas
aujourd'hui on ne voit vraiment et c'est
très bizarre quand on est français on va
je vais choquer aujourd'hui on ne voit
que du que du rose ou du rouge du bleu à
l'horizon s'était recueilli à eelv on
voit pas de danger on voit un monde qui
va de plus en plus vite depuis en de
mieux en mieux il ya de plus en plus
d'opportunités de plus en plus de savoir
et de talent et de plus en plus de
solutions et de plus en plus de capitaux
pour des projets c'est à dire que ce qui
manque à l'heure actuelle
c'est les projets parce que il y a en
gros une trentaine de trillions de
dollars
investis dans du monétaire dans des
prêts aux états etc l'argent il est là
pourquoi pour vulgariser un petit peu
ces capitaux sont basées sur une
province d'un travail futur si je
sentais distraite réellement leur fille
sont basées sur des bénéfices énormes
réalisés par des pays qui vendent des
matières premières ou sont très
efficaces
comme le
japon l'allemagne et la fim donc c'est
des réserves entre les emplois que ces
pays font et les surplus qu'ils ont donc
et ils vont en croissant
jean-manuel les matières premières
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
globalement
elles vont monter ou continuer à monter
oui je pense qu'il y en a beaucoup qui
sont redescendus ça s'est calmé et c'est
ramène à mesure où comme je viens de
dire il ya un milliard d'individus qui
accède à une consommation croissante il
faut bien qu'ils fonctionnent quelque
chose c'est donc ça va pousser le prix
de tous vers le haut des actions de
l'immobilier pour les plus riches des
warhol et des basques à et de l'art
contemporain et des matières premières
qu'il va falloir consommer et alors ce
qui est complexe dans ce raisonnement
c'est que évidemment on peut s'en
plaindre pour ceux qui eux n'ont pas
accès à ce monde là puisque ça rend tout
plus cher mais on ne peut pas s'en
plaindre pour le reste de l'économie car
cette montée des prix c'est aussi un
enrichissement notamment pour les
producteurs de ces matières premières
dans les pays émergents je vais faire
justement cette option de
mots grandissant avec une marche et
les pays émergents et et des pays
développés et regarder la croissance aux
états unis un mot peut-être sur la
spéculation sur les matières combien
justement
il faudrait vraiment vraiment vraiment
et c'est très très facile à faire
l'endiguer moi j'ai créé par le moins de
conduite j'ai créé une ong qui s'appelle
life organization et qui suggérait qu'il
y ait peut-être que vous allez très
opposés à ça qui est suggéré qu'il y ait
dans le monde des financements innovants
une taxe sur les transactions sur les
marchés dérivés de matières premières
notamment les futurs des options de
matières premières pour une raison sable
regardez c'est très très facile on a
tous les moyens modernes il y à des
chambres de compensation donc à chaque
fois qu'un futur sur un marché à terme
agricoles ou une option et échanger on
sait exactement in fine et qui est celui
qui l'a acheté et vendu et on peut
savoir si c'est un spéculateur pour le
compte d'un particulier dans une banque
privée pour le compte d'un fonds
d'investissement ou un agriculteur qui
en a besoin pour régler sa position il
n'y a aucun problème
prendre un pour cent sur l'aller-retour
aux spéculateurs qui se servent de ce
marché uniquement pour essayer de gagner
de l'argent et de ne rien prendre au
producteur est donc taxer ces marchés de
cette façon là une mini taxe à la marge
et donner cet argent soit aux états pour
se désendetter soit au développement
pour tout un tas de choses sont très
faciles à faire avec les agences
internationales contre la maladie pour
l'éducation dans le tiers monde c'est
quelque chose qui est absolument
indispensable et nécessaire est la seule
raison pour laquelle on ne le fait pas
c'est parce que il ya un lobby des
banques qui fait peur à la terre entière
et qui dit le monde à s'effondrer si on
ne le fait pas mais ça s'est vraiment
demandé à mon sens sur les faits et si
on le fait à mon sens c'est vraiment du
mou pour le chasser de ces faux c'est un
mensonge la recette exacte c'est exact
nous nous devons sanctionné d'une façon
ou d'une autre la spéculation pure et
permettre les opérations de couverture
des producteurs la difficulté c'est dans
la mise en oeuvre parce que il faut
avoir la corde 30 ou 40 pays car si nous
mettons ça dans toute l'europe et que on
retrouve dans une île lointaine de cni
trente banques qui font ça à partir de
là où de caraïbes si vous préférez donc
pour ça il faut avoir
l'accord des 30 principaux pays dans le
monde à commencer par les états unis
mais c'est fondamental de faire ça et il
va ça va pénétrer lentement les élites
américaines européennes et asiatiques je
pense que dans les 10 à 15 ans qui
viennent on aura fait un progrès
un mot là-dessus
je vous en prie monsieur terme en raison
c'est compliqué de convaincre les les
élites
ça fait 32 ans que je travaille dans le
monde des finances j'ai des copains donc
depuis ce temps-là dont certains ont des
grands exploits nos états unis j'en ai
appelé deux parmi les plus grands agent
pour leur dire soutiens moi sur cette
micro taxe sur les marchés dérivés 7 il
ya deux ans j'essaye encore de les
ravoir au téléphone ils me prennent pour
un fou voilà ils veulent ils en veulent
pas ils ont tort et un jour ils
comprendront oui vous comprendre que la
foule se rend à leur porte ça c'est sûr
hervé parler des élites quand vous le
concept élite cédé 1% le fameux 1%
qu'est-ce que ça résonne qu'est-ce qu'on
va dire élite pour vous d'élite pour moi
c'est d'abord les gens responsables
donc il faut qu'ils aient des
responsabilités et on n'a pas de
responsabilité si on n'a pas de pouvoir
donc pouvoir
responsabilité
conjuguer les deux ensemble vous arrivez
un petit groupe d'hommes qui sont
quelques milliers dans le monde qui
peuvent prendre des décisions c'est ces
gens là qu'il faut convaincre ou
commencer par les banques centrales car
une banque ne va pas aller à l'encontre
de ce que lui dit une banque sont crades
centrale parce que s'il le fait et une
banque peut toujours avoir une crise de
liquidité ou ou une autre crise d'une
autre nature elle a besoin de la banque
centrale donc il y a ce peut-être dix
mille personnes qui prennent des
décisions et à 20 qui compte ce sont les
20 premières banques centrales du monde
si ensemble elle décide que ce qui vient
d'être proposé et que je soutiens
entièrement c'est à dire une taxe sur la
pure spéculation
qui n'est pas complexe à mettre en
oeuvre et mise est appliquée nous
aurions fait un pas en avant
considérable car que faire de cet argent
en effet c'est une très bonne question
mais collectons le d'abord et puis
ensuite on trouvera des applications
utiles de parlement je voudrais redire
sur la commission trilatérale ce fameux
complexe ce fameux concept d'élite
est-ce que vous pouvez nous développer
un petit peu vous expliquer ce qu'est la
commission trilatérale commençons sont
effectués les prises de décision est ce
qu'il ya un comité directeur ça se passe
un petit peu comme les gens qui dirigent
la banque centrale est ce que ce sont
les gens influents vous aiguille essayé
de me désister à la rentrée dans des
locaux vides et de la commission
trilatérale vient de david rockefeller
il ya 35 ans il a réuni
quelques dizaines d'européens
d'américains d'eau japonais en leur
disant écoutez on a des problèmes en
commun par exemple
les relations avec la chine par exemple
les
relations avec ce qui était à l'époque
l'urss
essayons d'avoir des positions communes
qu'ils soient dans l'intérêt général est
ce que la commission trilatérale fait
pression pour par exemple
lancé une taxe sur la spéculation
elle pourrait hélas pourquoi il ne le
fait pas parce que l à
le mot pressions me gêne à partir du
moment où vous avez 150 européens
120 américains 150 asiatique nous en me
disant avoir des chinois dans notre
groupe qui ont écouté les raisons pour
lequel on devrait continuer à libérer le
commerce
contrôlé beaucoup plus ardemment le
système bancaire éviter la spéculation
être d'une plus grande générosité à
l'intérieur des pays à l'extérieur et
globalement vis-à-vis des plus pauvres
ça crée un mouvement et notre rôle n'est
pas de prendre des décisions c'est de
prendre des orientations
reprises par des dirigeants de tous
bords
nous avons toujours des dirigeants
politiques qui viennent d'un parti et
qui viennent de l'opposition nous avons
des gens qui viennent des syndicats et
et du et des affaires est ensemble on
essaye d'élaborer des solutions au
problème des migrations des capitaux et
nous essayons ensemble de travailler et
le seul fait de travailler ensemble
pendant trois jours quelques années de
suite fait que notre mentalités évoluent
hervé
sur l'organisation
[Musique]
kankankan la commission trilatérale
accès à des gens très important alors
nous avait dit de
syndicalisme oui absolument est-ce que
d'un point de vue extérieur ça peut être
perçu par la population comme une
collusion ainsi que des syndicats se
retrouvent du chef d'entreprise et des
journalistes autour d'une table pour
vulgariser se tape la pomme se font la
bise ou échanges sur des sujets un peu
plus complexe est ce que vous trouvez
pas qu'un 6 puis un conflit d'intérêts
et je veux prendre exemple des gens puis
sont une caste j'aime pas cocasse mais
des gens puissants une certaine élite
comme dans tout échantillon de
population il ya souvent des délinquants
ou des gens qui ne sont pas de bonne foi
est ce que vous pensez pas que ces gens
qui ce tout petit pour cent au sein de
tout petits pourcents là l'impact de
nuisance peut être très très important
et comment vous faites pour dire chasser
les viviers anti canard vous savez c'est
très simple la règle de david
rockefeller s'il ya un doute sur
l'intégrité de qui que ce soit dans une
dent dans le groupe de la trilatérale il
est immédiatement sorti c'est arrivé
c'est arrivé ça lui manque et non non
non pas aujourd'hui jamais y aura
jean manuel vouliez parler je disais que
je voulais réagir à dire qu'une fois de
plus l'ennemi quand il veut que la
commission trilatérale se réunit et fait
des suggestions il ya le bing un verre
souvent qui se met en place pour que les
choses n'arrivent pas notamment par
exemple dans le cadre des micro taxe sur
les marchés financiers et 7 et 7 est ce
le bing est inspiré une fois de plus de
l'envi de bonus c'était il ya tout un
tas de bus qui se disent oh là là mais
si on fait ça je vais pas pouvoir
continuer à gagner autant d'argent à
faire ce que je veux il faut surtout
arrêter et du coup et ça c'est assez
puissant parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui en veulent des bonus et je dois dire
quand même la chaussiette c'est que il
me semble que dans cet univers là dans
cet univers là et dans d'autres univers
qui est celui je veux pas des très
grandes sociétés il ya énormément de
gens qui croient mérité des très gros
salaires qu'ils ont et c'est faux c'est
absolument faux car en réalité si vous
essayez de réfléchir
ou et la création de valeur est ce que
c'est dans l'activité de l'individu où
on sait ce que tout ce que
l'organisation la société apporte à cet
individu pourvoir faire son activité je
vous prenez par exemple les traders pour
être trader c'est à dire pour pouvoir
fabriquer un produit qu'au bout de la
chaîne on va vendre très cher à un
client quelque part il faut des lignes
de crédit des bureaux de la crédibilité
et c'est tout un système monstrueux
qu'il faut gérer et le gars qui est là
on peut prendre on peut l'ôter on peut
en mettre un autre il est assez
remplaçable est donc en réalité la
valeur appartient à 98% à l'organisation
et à 2% à un individu est un ensemble à
vis d'une eu de collusion essaie de
faire croire que c'est le contraire que
c'est 50 50 et tant que ça continuera où
on sera en échec mais c'est faux c'est
juste faux airs vers des solutions
apportées sont s'il y en a il y en a une
c'est de ne pas faire ce qu'a fait chase
mort quand chez smorgon a perdu 9
milliards l'année dernière et c'est une
banque oui une très grande banque la
première banque mondiale et le patron en
2013 a reçu 23 millions de voyages à 20
3 millions votre milliards non 23
millions de bonus est colossale pour un
individu qui a perdu 9 milliards
voilà alors ce que je veux dire c'est
que que faire avoir des conseils
d'administration responsable que la
banque centrale
vérifie que les normes de rémunération
des dirigeants soit cohérente et juste
car là où il ya injustice sa répercute
sur l'intégrité à tous les niveaux d'une
organisation on n'a pas parlé de
sanctions ça on aurait dû renvoyer le
monsieur daïmon jamie dimon avait
absolument il a perdu 9 milliards
renvoyer ou le mettre en prison ça c'est
votre problème c'est pas le mien 1 le
mien c'est que les banques doivent
gérer leur
conseil d'administration
leurs dirigeants en fonction de
l'intérêt à long terme des clients de la
maison et de l'industrie hélas si on
prend le cas de ces piments blanc 9
milliards de provisions un président qui
reçoit 23 millions
ça n'est pas cohérent avec l'intérêt
général alors justement
le mot l'intérêt général
dans la commission trilatérale dans dû
normalement y avant tout c'est grand
c'est bon en même temps que les
particuliers comme il arbore aussi c est
faire pourquoi pas et vous parliez tout
à l'heure de représentation de toutes
catégories oui où sont les jeunes sont
les jeunes aux études je suis ravi de
cette question parce que nous sommes en
train de formuler la proposition à
l'intérieur de la commission trilatérale
de recruter des gens de 30 à 45 ans
parce que les autres ont quand même un
âge plus avancé et de façon à les
intégrer dans notre réflexion mais ça
prend du temps parce que vous êtes vous
et il a réussi arrivée de d'inviter des
gens des représentants va dire de de la
sagesse populaire quelque part
gelabert qui me vient en tête n'est plus
là dessus il est plus long mais des
représentants de ce type là
est ce qu'on a pris un abbé pierre
laïque
à l'intérieur d'eux
oui on prend des gens qui ont
qui ont une réflexion qui n'est pas
altérée altérer
ni par l'argent ni par la position
politique on a des gens qui sont des
sages
oui parce que je voudrais je voudrais
dire un mot de même que j'ai dit que
l'ennemi des solutions qu'on procès on
va dire le bonus et dont les biens l'a
vu dans le cas de monsieur dimon qui lui
tendent au tout en haut et qui lui se
d'un trop gros bonus qui permet à tout
le monde d'en bas dans la voix aussi je
crois que la solution et quand vous
dites par l'entraidé vincent banque
centrale qui devrait commencer à agir
c'est vrai et je sais que banques
centrales sont souvent soudan
indépendant du poids politique mais je
pense que la seule solution vraiment et
politique c'est à dire qu' il faut que
je montre ce que vous dites que
suffisamment d'individus dans la société
prenne conscience à la fois des
problèmes et des solutions pour élire
des politiciens qui eux
imposeront de solution et prenons un
exemple de comment ça peut se faire
comment ça peut se faire à la marge
qu'il faut déjà avoir des politiciens
qui soit suffisamment à ce moment là
volontaire il suffit détacher de la
haute finance pour pouvoir imposer ses
décisions puisqu'ils savent à l'heure
actuelle que s'ils s'imposent ce type de
décision marchés financiers comme le dit
monsieur de quatre mois tout à l'heure
si ça passe pas tout moi ça passera par
à côté et leur prochain monbaerts haute
je pense que d'abord il faut faire une
prise de conscience générale auprès du
plus grand nombre possible de personnes
il faut qu'un jour un politicien majeur
dans un pays majeur la france l'italie
l'espagne des états unis l'angleterre
l'allemagne soit élu sur un thème qui
reprend ces problématiques de façon
centrale et que peu à peu il impose au
reste c'est un rappel de tippingpoint il
ya un moment donné où ça va s'infléchir
le point de basculement et où ces
problématiques vont se diffuser dans la
société ça ne peut être que par la prise
de conscience des individus qui élisent
des politiciens qui leur disent oui ce
thème là c'est le mien je m'approprie je
leur prends et je n'impose et je vais
vous dire quelque chose qui va peut-être
vous surprendre on a failli et ça ne
veut pas dire que je vote pour lui ça ne
veut pas dire que j'ai soutenu ce qu'il
a fait par ailleurs on a failli avoir ça
en france avec nicolas sarkozy qui à la
fin de son mandat avait parfaitement
compris une chose c'était l'intérêt de
la taxe de la micro taxe sur les marchés
innovants et qu'ils voulaient l'imposé
juste sur ce sujet là il était très près
d'être le premier politicien majeur qui
était prêt à porter ce sujet là
c'est exact enfin c'est factuel ce qui
est dit
comment créer un mouvement enfin il faut
d'abord convaincre les journalistes
économiques il faut convaincre
des
des journaux tout court il faut avoir
des réunions avec des députés moi j'ai
participé à certaines de ces réunions il
faut dire que nos députés connaissent
assez peu de choses sur les questions
financières et économiques et peuvent
s'améliorer mais ils sont souvent
curieux et c'est un long travail
pédagogique
justement on est journaliste
peut-être que c'est ça ne pas assez
relayé par les médias mainstream et lui
profitera de cette petite réflexion pour
me dire comment se fait-il que des
dix simplement dix personnalités se
regroupant dans un hôtel
ahmed souffou de paparazzi alors que
vous même quand vous vous réunissez pour
la trilatérale
personne n'en parle mais bah on fait
référence par rapport aux villes veulent
berg qui s'est déroulé en angleterre qui
adhéraient énormément de paparazzi
d'obtenir nos portes mais mais mais à
l'intérieur
il n'ya vous n'avez pas accès à ce qui
étaient débattus et on se souvient de
monsieur yves calvi notamment il n'était
qu' il ya peut-être deux ans qu'il
découvrait ce qu'était clé le groupe
bilderberg sur sa propre antenne votre
addition du journalisme
si vous voulez le le le
c'est une bonne question
mais je vais je vais pas répondre d'une
façon
qui seraient induites par votre question
on devait me je ne pense pas que la
trilatérale et ayant été à son comité
exécutif
doivent faire de la publicité
s'expliquer
parce que c'est pas son objet son objet
est bien précis c'est de prendre les
sujets qui nous fâche avec les états
unis la chine le japon
sujet monétaire liberté de circulation
des hommes
qualité de la justice
efforts militaires toutes ces questions
là et d'en discuter
de façon privée et de faire émerger
d'autres idées qui vont influencer en
gros 400 personnes dans le monde c'est
ça notre objectif est ce qu'on peut
faire une suggestion oui la suggestion
qu'on aurait à formuler c'est de rendre
une partie de vos travaux publics que
l'internet puisse aussi réfléchir avec
vous et que vous puissiez bénéficier de
l'intelligence collaborative d'internet
je pense qu'à l'heure actuelle nous
pensons à l'heure actuelle que la force
de l'internet c'est de mettre en série
et les cerveaux et il ya il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de personnes sur le net
pourrait peut-être vous aider donc
essayer de rendre un peu plus public vos
travaux d'avoir des live stream on vous
conférence sans rendre publique il ya un
proverbe renseignement qui dit si tout
le monde parle rien ne marche mais si
personne ne parle ça
oui oui oui que nous du scion améliorer
notre communication vous avez raison
la réalité commeinhes que depuis 30 ans
nous avons fait évoluer les mentalités
aux états unis par rapport à l'europe la
russie et la chine en chine par rapport
aux libertés même chose
provisoirement à une époque en russie
nous avons renforcé la tendance au libre
échange nous avons établi des ponts très
nombreux et invisible qui doivent leur
excepté dans la collaboration en europe
avec la russie et les etats-unis la
chine et le japon dans le domaine
scientifique
donc on a fait un travail invisible
important permettez-moi dire que je veux
que robert un peu ce que disent nos amis
de saint claude youth et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on a extrêmement besoin
et je pense que ce sont les internautes
et ce sont des gens partout dans le
monde qui ont besoin d'une haute
autorité morale dans laquelle ils
puissent avoir confiance car il ya une
vraie crise de confiance en même temps
qu'il y à une diffusion massive du
savoir c'est à dire qu'il ya de plus en
plus de gens qui comprennent les
problèmes et qui évidemment étant
incapables ou impuissants des réseaux de
se mette à désespérer et beaucoup de
jeunes sont dans cet état là donc s'il y
avait une haute autorité morale je
comprends très bien depuis 30 ans vous
avez influencer un petit nombre de
décideurs mais je crois que si c'était
possible si vous pouviez être
représentatifs d'une morale
crédible vis-à-vis d'un très très grand
nombre de gens ça serait pas mal non
plus je rebondis justement sur cette
morale ainsi que sur les personnes
influentes dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure
quelque part chacun agissant un peu pour
sa part l'os
au sein de ces cercles le monde
extrêmement influent
vous comptez sur une sorte d' équilibre
des intérêts
nous laisse combats opposent craindre
nous gens extérieurs à ces à ces cercles
eu des convergences d'intérêts
parmi les personnes des idiots nerfs qui
vous pousserait vers quelque chose qui
ne va pas forcément dans le sens du bien
commun
ce que nous ne nous ira pas un équilibre
des intérêts il va y avoir un équilibre
des débats c'est à dire que nous allons
trouver des américains qui vont être
très
opposés à certaines politiques en
afrique ou ou ailleurs des japonais qui
ne veulent pas libérer leur
commerce interne nous allons trouver
toutes ces opinions exprimés est parce
qu elles seront exprimées avec force
prenons la libération du commerce au
japon par des américains et des arts
poney les dirigeants japonais vont
revenir chez eux et dire écoutez il faut
il faut prendre ça en considération et
ils vont contribuer à faire évoluer à
évoluer vers creux
vers plus de démocratie parce que c'est
le thème central donc plus de liberté
plus de gens qui participent aux
décisions plus de considération pour
l'intérêt général alors est ce que nous
comprenons bien à tout moment ce qu'est
l'intérêt général il ya matière à
s'améliorer et nous l'essayons nous
venons vu venir des gens opposés à nos
vues et qui ont des vues opposées entre
eux de façon à bien discuter bon
nous restons je pense mode s c'est à
dire que très bien on débat on a des
spécialistes et puis chacun repart dans
son pays en essayant de faire bouger la
chose
n'est pas illusoire d'imaginer de voir
les groupes tels que le vôtre poussée
des nouvelles solutions un détail dans
les transports dans la transition
énergétique qui s'imposent a aujourd'hui
des nouvelles solutions qui pourraient
mettre en péril des lobbys qui baisse
des milliers en france on fait trop est
ce que vous arrivez jusqu'au choc
frontal la commission trilatérale
suffisamment ses préconisations
on arrive au choc frontal on arrive à ce
que sur des sujets comme l'énergie nous
avons deux thèses
exprimé à une réunion où il ya 150
personnes absolument opposé cresson
le degré d'investissement qui doit être
soutenue par les états sur les nouvelles
énergies
il ya une thèse d'un grand pays européen
qui a
investi des dizaines de milliards et
qui n'a obtenu aucun résultat
et vous avez d'autres pays qui comme le
nôtre qui pensent que
une industrie nucléaire
très exigeante en matière de sécurité
est quelque chose qu'il faut conserver
tandis que nous avons des vues
absolument opposé à la france qui
s'exprime à la trilatérale jean-manuel
vous avez été gestionnaire de fortune
[Musique]
est-ce que vos clients vous demandez
simplement du roman où il y avait
vraiment une éthique dans
l'investissement est ce que par exemple
vous aviez une partie de votre
portefeuille pour de nouveaux projets ou
des choses comme ça c'est très spécial
dans cette période où j'ai fait ce
métier on avait un mélange
notre but était de
soutenir financièrement
des entrepreneurs compétents
dans des métiers intéressants c'est à
dire de ce point de vue là dans des
métiers à bonnes marges donc tout
l'exercice que je fais pendant les
quinze ou seize ans que je fais ce
métier c'était de trouver des gens qui
étaient fort dans des métiers qui était
bon et de trouver des façons avec
diverses clients de leur permettre de
grandir de ce point de vue là il y avait
une vitalité qui était évidente c'est
qu'on a aidé dans certains cas la
création massive d'emplois puisque on a
mis des capitaux aux mains de gens qui
partent en ados sont arrivés à cette
ville c'est pas mal mais je ne dis pas
que c'était le seul but le but c'était
de trouver des façons le court terme
vous avez envie de vous dire que le vent
terme c'est une super création ratait
devient un investissement mais c'était
pas ça l'idée l'idée c'était de trouver
dans le monde entier et dans différentes
industries des gens qui étaient très
bons dans ce qu'ils faisaient et de leur
donner accès au capital nécessaire à
leur croissance ça a bien marché à une
question est ce que l'éducation est un
placement avec de bonnes marges
je ne sais pas pour vous arrêter je suis
pas sûr que l'éducation soit un domaine
qu'ils soient à 100% et uniquement de la
responsabilité des privés je compterai
de forcément aussi de l'état mais
d'une façon générale
les du question et le placement avec la
meilleure marge puisque c'est par
l'éducation par de savoir que l'on crée
la richesse la croissance
le savoir la démocratie et l'emploi donc
sans éducation il n'y a rien
oui mais ses dépens qu'il fait est ce
que c'est l'état ou est ce que c'est des
privés
bonne question hervé
je vous mets oui je souris parce que je
pense que ce camp des clients
me confie de l'argent
je pense long terme j'ai toujours pensé
long terme donc c'est un placement raté
non nous avons choisie il ya quinze ans
d'investir dans des pme
une pme ya quinze ans une nouvelle pm
chaque année
on a créer 1000 emplois
et on l'a fait selon des règles qui vont
à l'encontre du marché pas un sou de
l'état pas un sou des banques
les particuliers qui s'associe le font
pour 15 à 20 ans et ça a marché ça a
marché parce qu'on a eu d un dirigeant
qui savait choisir là où ils
investissent et c'est tout donc
je continue rebonds donc
moi je crois que les gens qui vous
confient leur argent ils ont ce que
j'appelle une propension au risque il
faut en tenir compte et s'ils sont prêts
à prendre des risques il est haute et
prêts à les prendre avec nous eh bien on
les a pris
on a gagné d'argent pendant quinze ans
on n'a pas perdu une société
et on s'est
concentré sur le fait qu' on n'avait pas
d'argent des banques et pas d'argent de
l'état ce qu'est ce qui est intéressant
dans le risque c'est que ce que vous
dites prouve que
souvent ce que des gens pensent être
extrêmement risqués ne l'est pas
tellement est ce qu'il pense ne pas être
risqué l'été nommément vous donne un
exemple simple si en 2007 vous décidez
d'acheter un panier des meilleures
valeurs du monde les cinq meilleures
valeurs du cac 40 et en même temps de
mettre un peu d'argent dans le soutien
d'une pme dans le domaine du numérique
par exemple eh bien vous vous dites mon
panier cac 40 il est pas risquer mon
panier pme il est risqué c'est le
contraire le panneau le beignet pas
risqué selon les canons de la gestion -
80 % en deux ans et plus l'autre by
réussi donc c'est vraiment 7,7 cette
appréciation du risque c'est vraiment
quelque chose de clécy des centaines
d'actes énormément de liquidités que
certains certains ont pris des positions
en 2009 sur des bancaires en prévoyant
dans le fait que les états ne laisserait
pas tomber les banquiers sont fait
énormément de profits je vais pas vous
citer le gestionnaire d'un fonds
américain qui a pris 16 9 il ya entre
2009 et 2011
c'est aussi lecture si vous avez une
lecture un petit peu vers vers du
système financier on peut faire
énormément d'argent il faut pas ce qu'il
ya de bien faire est d'essayer lorsque
marché baisse non c'est pas être
baissiers c'est un imbécile 7 mètres des
poteaux ption à la baisse pour parier
que ça va baisser c'est une psychologie
des investisseurs qui qui peut être
respectable respecté
jugé marc compte parier que les états ne
lâcheront pas leur banque et faire de la
spéculation là-dessus ça peut être
discutable je ne va pas on va pas en
revenir dessus
ça mériterait une autre interview on va
vous poser une dernière question est ce
que mon collègue à d'autres questions
j'aurais bien aimé voir un digg ou de
votre part sur le marché transatlantique
qui soit les marchés tentent de
l'antique et plus particulièrement le
fait que les très grosses sociétés on
pensera monsanto puis ceux des mains
éventuellement à intenter un procès un
pays ce qui est totalement
[Musique]
ubuesque
actuelle mais
on peut penser maîtrise un peu les
nôtres je le souhaitais savoir ce que
vous en pensiez
on mettait à la même échelle en fait je
ne marchais transatlantique on prend des
sociétés dont certaines ont des chiffres
d'affaires
égale un pourcentage significatif de
certains états européens c'est une
réalité bon elle crée des emplois et
créer de la richesse
elles sont
sous la loupe
des autorités diverses américaines
européennes et dans l'ensemble elle se
comporte à peu près bien dans l'ensemble
est ce qu'il y à des excès
récemment j'ai vu des des excédents dans
la chimie et dans le médical bon mais
quand vous prenez les
300 premières sociétés
mondiales
je dirais que ma critique n'est pas dans
ce qu'ils font mais de ce qu'ils ne font
pas c'est à dire qu'il y a plusieurs
milliers de milliards de dollars qu'ils
ne sont pas investis par ces sociétés
qui sont sur leur bilan et qui alimente
certes la liquidité mondiale mais nous
aimerions mieux qu'elle les investisse
pour créer de la richesse et de l'emploi
et elles ne le font pas et la vraie
question c'est pourquoi
la réponse est la réponse est un manque
de projet avant de visibilité non je
pense pas je pense que
quand je prenais des sociétés qui ont 30
50 milliards de liquidités et qui
n'ont pas en interne à travers leurs
centres de recherche à travers tous les
éléments les propositions de deux de
leurs commerçants créer suffisamment de
nouvelles idées qui elles doivent être
mises en oeuvre et donc
on accuse jamais mais il ya là un
problème de direction générale deux
dernières questions
c'est toujours les interviews
des préconisations des conseils jean
manuel ros en un conseil pour les
internautes qui n'ont garde
choisissez le sujet si on reste
je vais divisé en deux on en a parlé à
d'autres occasions il faut croire que
les gens jeunes doivent absolument
comprendre internet ce n'est pas du tout
le sujet d'aujourd'hui mais il ya des
enjeux très importants notamment au
niveau de la vie privée sur internet
aujourd'hui il devrait dans l'idéal en
savoir le maximum notamment apprendre à
coder ça leur permettrait de comprendre
exactement ce qui se passe dans le monde
d'internet mais par ailleurs
on est en france ici et on est je crois
très très très influencé par l'esprit
français par des problèmes français par
tout ce qui s'est passé ici je crois que
les gens évidemment en france quand on
parle de croissance mondiale quand on
dit à quel point ça va vite et bien
quand je vous dis l'innovation dans le
monde entier est en train de changer de
monde et on va vers une croissance très
important des 1 qui viennent gens nous
disent vous êtes fous vous parlez de
quoi donc je vous dis aux jeunes qui
nous écoutent c'est vrai c'est possible
il faut le ramener en france il faut
aussi le faire en france mais nous
sommes dans une période d' opportunité
exceptionnelle non
et il faut le plus possible voir comment
les autres pays réussisse pourquoi est
ce que les états unis marche si bien
maintenant et je vais
je vais vous donner un élément de
réponse
aux états unis l'année dernière
il y avait eu un million 3 d'émigrés qui
sont venus dont 800 milles si vous
voulez sont venus d d d d d d d des
familles qui sont qui roule hommes
étaient partis ensuite affamés les huit
enfants regroupement familial et puis
quelques centaines de milliers sont
venus pour des raisons politiques mais
il y a eu 140 mille hommes de conrad de
compétences venus du monde entier vous
parlez vous parlez des états unis vous
parlez du cap vert c'est là le papier
pour pouvoir traîner des cerveaux à
l'extérieur absolument et
140 milles
nous pendant cette période
on a perdu 30 mille français compétents
c'est à dire par rapport à notre
population 65 compte 320 nous avons
perdu autant en homme de compétences que
les américains ont gagné en personnes
hommes et femmes de compétences et donc
je dis que nous devons veiller à ce
point là avec acharnement à ne pas
perdre nos meilleurs éléments il y avait
en belgique 3000 français dans la cuma
commune aisée il y en a onze mille il ya
cinq ans il y en a onze mille
aujourd'hui il ya des dizaines de
450000 français en grande bretagne des
dizaines de milliers en suisse et nous
avons perdu parmi les plus dynamiques
nous avons perdu entre 5 et 10 % des
français les plus dynamiques pour
l'étranger et ça nous devons le
surveiller et éviter
moi je vais dire sans réponse pourquoi
pourquoi ils partent pour quoi il parle
je me sens qui sont présentement sinon
oui c'est pas simplement c'est le fait
que depuis
seize 185
les bons vient d'une famille qui a était
protestante
donc
les élites qui font de l'argent qui
créent de la richesse sont mal vus ça a
été le cas en 585 ça a été le cas à la
fin
des 8e mais absolument table bien géré
d'une fumée sans feu
si si
la population à cet esprit critique face
à un homme riche c'est peut-être de
transparence peut-être de l'envy
peut-être aussi de une réalité pour
certaines quand je ne crois pas comment
je ne crois pas mais je vais vous donner
ma version de jours battu certaines
familles venues faire de la spéculation
pendant les gardes à la deuxième guerre
mondiale
ça a laissé quand même des traces au
niveau de certains donc respecter les
gens qui investissent et qui font de
l'argent c'est vraiment france qu'on a
un peu tendance à pas trop et inspecté
ce qui je pense une erreur parce que il
ya il faut avoir des leaders il faut
avoir des pointes de diamant des gens
qui prennent des risques mais il faut
aussi respecter les gens qui ont eu là
où qu'ils ont vu certaines malversations
il faudrait il faudrait que la richesse
soit vertueuse et ce qui l'aiderait le
plus est vertueuse c'est qu'elles soient
transparentes et assumée et on a en
france un très très grand problème
culturel qui le suivant la france et le
pays de l'égalité égalité liberté
fraternité
mais en france en réalité on ne libre de
tout
sauf d'être différent on doit être égale
l'égalité était obligatoire dans les
pays anglo saxons la différence est
assumée c'est à dire que le but de
société c'est de permettre à chacun
d'assumer sa différence donc en france
quand on a une différence on est obligé
de lagardère dans un périmètre cacher
quand sa différence à soit l état
physique elle est pas par la mode et pas
par le foulard le turban ou la kippa
mais elle est par l'argent eh bien on la
cache c'est l'art problème de la france
est entièrement que dans un monde
principalement libéral principalement
anglo saxons place l'allemand axée sur
la possibilité pour les individus
d'avoir accès à leurs différences la
france ne peut pas mettre le droit à la
différence en avant on l'a vu une façon
très simple on a un président qui est
élu en 2007 en disant je vais faire une
rupture on comprend ce que c'est que
cette rupture cette rupture c'est je
vais
vous obliger à
exceller je vais vous obliger à
fonctionner ça va être obligatoire alors
on lui dit bon c'est pas sympa mais on
va te laisser essayer ça marche pas et
du coup on a un président qui après
était lui en disant je vais être normal
c'est à dire je ne vais pas être
différent les deux sont excessifs
c'est la confiance dans l'avenir de la
france parce que nous avons 65 millions
d'habitants que nous avons un taux de
croissance
important que nous avons heureusement un
taux d'émigration très important
immigration de graphiques oui
démographique important que nous avons
des gens qui viennent d'un peu partout
d'europe et d'afrique du nord qui
veulent réussir et que ces éléments là
vont remuer secoué la société française
pour qu'elle aille de l'avant et que
j'ai tout à fait confiance que dans les
deux trois décennies qui viennent ils
renouvelleront les élites de la france
dans un sens qui bénéficiera à
l'ensemble du pays est sûre
nouveau version merci à vous
non
ce qui est véritablement intolérable
c'est la surveillance de masse comme le
disait rigole c'est la présomption de
culpabilité
c'est
des violations massives de nos libertés
individuelles qui ne peuvent en aucun
cas respecter le principe de
proportionnalité est parce qu on a enfin
rattraper notre retard sur les
américains et puis on va pouvoir montrer
line et sacs ou ces fermes aussi et on
s'est fait répondre superbe on va faire
de surveillance après le le souci c'est
pour la démocratie mais bon la réalité
du risque et camoufler à tous les
niveaux les banques ont des pertes en
interne très importante qu'elle ne
montre pas les banques centrales n'exige
par la transparence les organismes
chargés de faire les audits en dise
encore moins et les directions générales
se taisent dans toutes les langues
[Musique]